all right today's topic since it's
women's international month
let's keep going
[Music]
[Applause]
army captain sarah cudd would not give
up during the final moments of the
grueling 12-mile foot march to achieve
her expert field medical badge at fort
dix in new jersey
the last step in earning the badge was
to complete the 12 mile trek in three
hours did you see the other man just
did you see my name oh my god this is a
long ass day it's a long day for sure
[ __ ] i gotta cross that goddamn line oh
yeah
hey come on sarah pick your ass up [ __ ]
did you see that this guy just strobed
he just casually stroll
yeah i'm out of that
while carrying 70 pounds of gear with 13
minutes to go the captain fell to her
knees in exhaustion but with her
soldiers cheering her on she rose to her
feet and crossed the finish line
it's more like if you don't finish this
[ __ ] we're all doing push-ups get your
ass up let's go
she's a captain
that's not happening
no
okay when you're a commissioned officer
you're good it's not like ncos okay ncos
get treated like grunts yeah
officers they get the sweets is she
getting a rub down after this yo she get
whatever she wants okay cool you got her
[ __ ] ate by the nco2 goddamnit
[Applause]
captain cudd serves with army public
health command in fort knox kentucky she
was only one of the 46 candidates who
achieved the badge that day and the
public health command says up to 80
percent of people fail we think captain
sarah cudd really defines what
determination means and watching this
video is truly an inspiration to never
give up i feel inspired
but unsafe
i'm gonna tell you that i'm just being
real the other dudes stroll through
like it was nothing
but hey for me it's the groveling and
the praise that people get it's like
just for doing your job yeah
just doing what they're supposed to do
there was like a point in the military
where they transitioned they were really
allowing women to join the forces in
droves but they really wanted to
encourage it because from a public
relations standpoint it worked really
well and also to be fair many women in
the military was a very positive thing
because you needed as many recruits as
you can for certain jobs where women
would be proficient at so it was
overwhelmingly positive but the way that
they pushed some of them through the
success stories that they were trying to
pay like you would have marines right
who are males and would get passed on
for promotions for women who met an
inferior standard right even though they
were working for the same job yeah right
just for the standards of questions and
that's where
you have like that whole like
affirmative action within the military
which is absolutely counterproductive
and unfair to everybody else who's
trying to get it because every promotion
comes with a huge pay raise yeah
definitely better better postings better
opportunities in a lot of ways more
responsibility and the ability to keep
progressing right it's patently unfair
when i watch this video
and the whole [ __ ] pr piece about it
you were frustrated you were you were
triggered
i just cringe i don't i don't get
triggered because like at the end of the
day when it came to like physical tests
and all that stuff for me it was easy to
accept that [ __ ] because it wasn't that
difficult right but is this
it made me cringe how insulting the
standards were yeah
you put a dude in the same thing they'd
be like bro this is pathetic
that's what they would be looking at him
for
so that's why i look at this i'm like
really is this the standard you want to
set for these ladies listen there's
female service members who go balls to
the wall they go hard
right and they get the most amount of
respect from other dudes because dudes
see they trying to carry their own
weight irrespective of their gender
which
who's going to hate on that
but some of this [ __ ] like
i got really offended when i saw them
doing their push-ups on their knees on
their knees that's what killed me yeah
already you got to do less push-ups
[ __ ] you on your knees doing these
push-ups that's not even real yeah but
that's how desperate they were to get
them through the door yeah and the
difference is really big the difference
of push-ups that you have it's really
huge you need push-ups for nothing
no you can get down right now probably
give me a hundred so yes
versus just push-up push-ups but
shout-out to you dude you're just
walking down squawking
right look we love to
like
i don't know highlight the mediocrity or
person wanting like i guess persevering
against some that was difficult for them
but i was like you should have been
training for this and and being able to
do this a long time ago it's not like
these rucksack marks are the hardest
thing bar you have like some injury like
shin splints from having to do this
there should be no reason why you're
struggling when you've been in the
military that long
you know there's some folks in the
military who get in they pass your test
and then they just let themselves go
yeah because they don't have a job to
whatever they're not on the field like
that so rob and then they're still able
to stay because they give them relax i'm
like bro you all need to keep something
it's just like cops it's just like cops
there's some guys that get in the forest
and they
they don't
ever shoot
they have a gun they never go to a gun
range yeah they let themselves go
there's so many things wrong with this
yeah you know like her weapon's there
she falls to the ground that's a that's
dangerous that's dangerous that's a lie
even if it's unloaded like they make
sure that you don't make bad habits why
because if you actually are in the field
and you do have your rifle you drop it
like that a discharge can go off you can
kill a soldier like this is not stuff
you would normally price
also remember she's a captain if you
don't understand there's two tiers right
you got ncos which are non-commissioned
um officers and then you have
the commission members who are basically
people who have degrees or special
interests who are in leadership
positions okay obviously the pays
much higher for them than it is for the
ncos the ncos are in a leadership
position so imagine she's leading but
she's not leading by
example think about that
and i'm not even saying out of your unit
you got to be the most fit but if you're
at the back end you can bear you can't
barely pass
how do you set the example for the
troops that are under you and the truth
is that's why a lot of ncos don't
respect their commanding officers or a
lot of the people who are you know just
got their degrees i know they wouldn't
be able to do the same work as they
would physically
they would not yes
they were not every time i had a job i
had a boss and he was like being cocky
about his position and [ __ ] like that
and was yelling at me to do some [ __ ] i
was like do it yeah run the department
if you're not running it do it do what i
do in the time that i'm doing you're
easy it's easy for you to give [ __ ]
whenever you give [ __ ] but do what i do
yeah do do it yeah that's all we don't
respect them imagine like the difference
between you and somebody else is just
the fact that they have a degree yeah
their confidence level is not that much
higher
if
sometimes it's lower
but they got a degree mm-hmm and that
matters in them oh i just wanted to just
bring this up it's just one of those
things that cringe you know these
[ __ ] are even talking about
removing some of the physical tests
because
40 to 50 of women are failing just to
accommodate
they're talking about removing the
physical tests
because they can't
hey man listen i stopped my whole time
when i was in there i was actually very
shocked i didn't know it was going to be
like that i was very surprised by how
like slanted towards women a lot of the
brass is a lot of this
it's very strange but that's another
topic for another day
anything else you want to add no
let us know what you guys think the
comments below
huh
hear the music
i didn't call that black and when you
see me i'm wide burned a lot of money
and i smoke a lot of spikes i bring
[Music]
[ __ ] your wife
[Music]
[ __ ] your white wife